Oh! Will you help me?
Can you help me?
You don't need to be helped any longer.
You've always had the power to go back to Kansas.
I have?
Then, why didn't you tell her before?
Because she wouldn't have believed me.
She had to learn it for herself.
What have you learned, Dorothy?
Well,...
...I think...
...that it wasn't enough just to want to see Uncle Henry and Auntie Em.
And it's that, if I ever go looking for my heart's desire again,...
...I won't look any further than my own backyard.
Because if it isn't there,...
...I never really lost it to begin with.
Is that right?
That's all it is!
But that's so easy!
I should have thought of it for you.
I should have felt it in my heart.
No, she had to find it out for herself.
Now, those magic slippers will take you home in two seconds!